you know it's not like adolescents
aren't confused about sex and their
identity that's what adolescence is is
confusion about sex and identity
you know in general confusion about
everything what do i do who am i yeah
exactly and no wonder right because you
have a lot of choices ahead of you
and it's a tumultuous time there's a lot
of neurological reorganization
and so
so it's too many choices
well
look there's a huge literature on
consumer choice so let's say you you
might ask yourself
how many shampoos do you want to go look
at when you're shopping
one
five or three hundred
five five exactly why don't 300 because
one of those 300 is the best
diminishing returns on my investment
that's for sure that's for sure and like
how are you gonna evaluate 300 items for
quality you just no matter which one you
pick you've made a mistake
you know when you go into subway and you
say they say how do you want your
sandwich like i want you to figure that
out that's why i'm paying for it
you know if i have to make every
sandwich decision i might as well make
it
so so people drown in choice very
rapidly right
talk about anxiety right yes exactly
well that is anxiety it's terrible
anxiety and too many choices is anxiety
so and
it isn't like i it's not like i know the
answer to how much choice about your
gender you should have
but i think that you know we we need to
recognize that there is wide variation
in personality within women and within
men even though there are differences
and mostly men and women overlap by the
way so we're more the same than we are
different except at the extremes and
that matters
like if you're low in agreeableness
enough one in a hundred let's say you're
way more likely to be in prison
and so that's males
so there are not very many women in
prison
compared to men and
that's because
at the extremes there's a huge
preponderance of aggressive men
physically aggressive men
even though at the middle point there's
a lot of overlap people don't understand
this maybe maybe then the the other side
of the question is then
why are people so offended so easily i
think there's
more difficulty
for each side to speak to each other
people to
use the right terminology and words and
not offend someone than ever too so why
are why are people seemingly more easily
offended that's a really good question
you know it's it's hard to say because
people have been offended for a long
time the moral majority was offended for
a long time in the 80s you know i mean
and there was plenty of censorship and
that sort of thing
i
again it's one of those things that's
very difficult to track across time
it might be that we're exposed to more
things that offend us now
i mean you go on the net you if you
can't find something to be offended by
you're not trying very hard well that
could just be it right i mean imagine
that we never want to underestimate the
the impact of
insane technological transformation
you know i
mean you can see everything
all the time about anything
and so
i don't know if people are more easily
offended or if there's just way more
offensive things
so maybe it's a matter of just reducing
the amount of options reducing exposure
i mean is this a remedy for clarity for
less
um
volatility less
offensive less less chance to be
offended
well
who knows right i mean twitter seems to
be a good way of being offended
um continually
band offending yeah and you know that
might be a consequence of its structure
it's limited it's it makes it seems to
reward impulsivity
it seems to transmit bad better than
good
quite rapidly we don't know what these
technologies do to people or to
communication
maybe
so i don't know if people are more
easily offended than they used to be
they're offended about different things
more things because there's more things
possibly possibly right i mean it's been
interesting to see what's happened with
with sex over the course of my lifetime
i mean
in the 60s
there was this idea and it was probably
the consequence of the birth control
pill that well maybe sex is is free
right it's free and easy because well
now pregnancy wasn't necessarily a
consequence and venereal disease was
reasonably well under control and so
wasn't a blatant threat certainly not a
fatal one
and so people thought well
why not free love
well i think the reason for that is it's
complete rubbish
there's no free sex
it's too dangerous and so what's
happened is that from an emotional
standpoint are you speaking about from
an emotional standpoint or physically
physically and socially
well think of consent
okay when can you give consent
well you're thinking answer is we don't
know no under what conditions well what
constitutes consent
exactly
a whim
what if you change your mind
what if you're intoxicated what if
you're stoned
what if you're upset
what if you feel you've been manipulated
you know i mean because the issue of
consent is not if the act is serious
and you can debate about whether or not
that is and people have their
differences of opinion
it's certainly
emotionally
significant in all likelihood
so if it's significant
well then consent is important well what
constitutes consent well marriage does
so that's where sex was encapsulated
fundamentally
because their consent was never an issue
i mean there's all sorts of things that
weren't an issue because of that and it
wasn't like it was a magical solution to
everything but
so you know because
in the 60s the idea was that sex could
be casual well aids pretty much put the
end to that idea at least in part right
so and it definitely spread
as a consequence of promiscuity that was
definitely one of the driving factors
that
put aids everywhere so that was
not so good to put it mildly
and then the reaction on campuses is
well
what constitutes consent and the reason
that has become questionable is because
it's questionable
unless it's not serious but you know
i don't think that people really believe
that
so
they might wish they believed it
but there's plenty of emotional damage
done
as a consequence of
too quick intimacy i think that's
generally the case because in a
partnership that becomes intimate
there's usually one person who's more
emotionally invested than the other
probably almost inevitably yes i mean i
think inevitably in every situation
pretty much yeah yeah yeah pretty much
they can still be very high but
someone's still going to be more than
young
so this kind of leads to the the
conversation about individuality being
the way out of ideological traps
and
and the question is
how
how and what are the ways to know who
you are because i don't think that's i
don't think it's as easy as
it sounds like who is impossible
people are really complicated you're way
more complicated than anything else
except another person right you're the
most complicated thing that exists then
put two complicated people together and
yeah well you know hopefully they can
help each other sort themselves out at
least to some degree but yeah i mean
you're
to be self-aware completely is just not
possible because
you know what we try to do to understand
ourselves is
limit what we'll do and you do that to
other people too
say well i know you and then you punish
them if they do things you don't
understand that way they stay in the box
you put them in and there's downside to
that and an upside you know it's part of
the social contract not to do outrageous
things
although you could
so we all abide by these rules and that
simplifies us a lot right right that's
part of being polite is
you don't want the bank teller to be
complex
you want them to be polite and simple
so your limited understanding is
sufficient
and we do that with each other all the
time
except when we're emotional how do you
find the individuality your uniqueness
your specialness
well that probably manifests itself to a
large degree in what you're interested
in
which is difficult to know i think
that's also difficult to know i felt
like it took into my mid-30s before i'm
like oh yeah i'm really interested in
these things
were you interested in all sorts of
things sure yeah when i was young i did
all sports
i
you know then be was a teenager but it
wasn't until i was really in my 30s that
i really really realized how much i
enjoyed art how much i enjoyed
you know
creating and artistic things how much i
enjoyed nature
how much i enjoyed traveling in
alone time because i'm a bit of an
introvert um so it wasn't until i was in
my mid-30s so i figured that out to me
that creates some of my individuality
that's my that's that's who i am
but how do people how do people figure
that out so that they know who they are
so they don't
fall into ideological traps
well so the first question is is
knowing yourself the way out of an
ideological trap well it is to some
degree because
one size doesn't fit all right so you
have to be aware of how you differ
and i that does take a long time to
figure out who you are because you're
complicated
so
it might not be that surprising at all
that it took you till your mid-30s
before you started to have some sense of
who you really were because
people are very hard to understand it's
and we don't have a good
vocabulary generally speaking for
analyzing differences in people i mean
that the personality test i described is
a step in that direction
and but it's that lexicon that
vocabulary still isn't
popularly established let's say
so it isn't part of the conversations we
have about other people except
accidentally
i produce this other
technology at self-authoring that helps
people write about their past
analyze their faults and their virtues
and write a plan for the future
it's a useful way of figuring out who
you are you kind of have to hit yourself
against the world but
you know you tell the story about your
past and that that helps you understand
where you came from
you figure out your virtues and your
faults that sort of helps you understand
your strengths and weaknesses and then a
plan
gives you a course for the future
it's hard to do all that writing
but it's hard to blunder through life
too without a plan so it's hard either
way pick your heart you always talk
about that choose your
choose choose the difficult or the
difficult to choose you eventually and
you might not like it as much right
yeah well when it's necessary like i
wouldn't say to go to go out of your way
necessarily to make your life difficult
but if you have a difficult choice in
front of you and it's either abandon
what you're you know you should be doing
or do the difficult thing
well you're going to pay a price for
abandonment so
and i guess i would also say that to uh
to understand yourself it's
quite useful to try to not lie
as you tangle yourself up in your own
lies people think they can get away with
lying but
we you can't get away with falsifying
the structure of the world